У шість років я почав робити
музичні інструменти.
Сопілку в шість років я зробив.
Скрипку — в 12 років.
Скрипку, таку натуральну скрипку.
Мама не дурна.
Казала, що з музиканта
нема господаря.
Та й з коваля нема,
а ковальство в мене дуже...
Але був тут один дідок,
що сто років мав.
Казав мамі: «Анно, не бий ти хлопця,
з нього буде чоловік.
Ти дивись, аби він не крав,
щось поганого не робив.
А що хоче щось уміти,
допоможи йому».
Так мама купила мені
першу скрипку.
Я, як ту скрипку зловив, пішов...
У хаті в мами не рипів,
бо мама то не дуже [любила].
Мама музику любила ось так
послухати, але я не вмів ще файно.
Пішов собі на горбик вище хати,
та й вже так десь
від обіду до вечора.
Вже вечір робиться,
вже сонце зайшло.
Я вже граю, йду граючи до хати,
двері були отворені [відчинені],
то було десь
в таку пору, під осінь.
Та й вже граю мелодію.
А мама так стояла біля пічки,
та й кліпає очима отак,
та й більше нічого не казала.
Вже узріла,
що зі мною нема ради.
Цимбали в 24 роки зробив.
Ліру зробив у 62 роки,
бо не мав часу,
бо я ковалював усе життя.
У кузні був у колгоспі.
Я мав таке бажання
і таке розуміння настільки,
що я собі інструмент побачив,
я вже собі зрозумів,
як його починати,
як його робити,
аби він грав.
Це з бузини робиться, з ліщини
і з явора, з будь-якої деревини навіть.
Грали отак: біля овець,
як випасали вівці, корови випасали.
Косили сіно — теж грали.
Це дуже було в повазі
в давніх людей.
А зараз вже ніхто
не хоче на цьому грати.
Треба своє бажання.
Таке природне бажання,
так, щоби людина любила.
Треба все любити.
Хоче навчитися грати —
треба любити.
Любите ви це, обожнюєте,
і хочете, і мусите — я знаю по собі.
Це сопілки, от бачите,
тут будуть...
Але тут є ще...
Це насвердлено.
Якими я свердлами свердлю
сопілки, от бачите.
Оцю скрипку, окрім
струн, я робив.
Все — моя робота.
Музикантові не треба ніякі роботи́
робити такі фізичні, важкі роботи́.
А ковальство — тим більше.
У мене так попало,
що я і коваль був,
і зараз ще ковалюю
дещо трохи, вже не дуже.
Ну й музикантом був усе життя.
І найголовніше —
скрипка у мене була.
Я все самоук.
А от отака скрипка,
довбанка зветься.
Бачите, з якого шматка?
Це маю оце все видовбати,
всередині все.
Тут стінка тільки лишається
три міліметри.
Це ліра буде,
ось бачите.
Це лише таке, тут треба дошку
верхню, то все доробити,
так, щоб я крутив,
грав, от бачите.
Я мав 12 років,
коли я це побачив вперше.
Генцар Дмитро.
Він мав вже 82 роки,
це що і я це побачив,
то він грав біля церкви весною.
Я не мав часу, я в 12 років це
побачив, та й то так мріяв.
А ще я і не мав чим,
таке, ще дитина була.
Але...
Пережив ціле життя,
ковалював у колгоспі,
у 14 років пішов
до коваля вчитися.
І так робив, вже зостався,
що робив до кінця.
На пенсію...
У 62 роки я зробив
таку першу ліру.
Я не мав її ні в руках, нічого,
просто я собі так...
У мене такі мрії були.
Багато де співав.
То Генцар Дмитро,
я від нього переймав,
цю мелодію навіть перейняв.
Я в 12 років це чув,
а в 62 роки зробив,
і це я не забув нічого.
О, бачите, це трембіта.
Я роблю, та йде все
для перевезення,
оскільки їхав в Америку,
то в Польщу, то в Москву.
То має бути така — з двох шматків
по півтора метри.
Щоб воно, коли складені дві половини,
потому труба така виходить.
І то склеюється.
А потому, вже коли висохло,
обробив все файно,
і тоді вже корою обгортати.
Трембіта мала бути на похороні
обов'язково, і зараз використовують.
На полонині теж обов'язково.
То не було годинників,
ні телефонів, нічого.
Бере з собою бугар той (це вівчар),
та він іде собі туди горами,
вівці випасає.
А вáтаг має тут,
або цей завідувач.
Ну й вони собі тим скликали,
мали такі сигнали.
Це усі мої інструменти, от бачите,
які свердла, все, що треба мені.
Цей станок я теж зробив
сам, от бачите.
Музиканти без мене
не обходяться, знаєте.
Це все різьбив,
це все моя робота.
Гуцули дуже робочі,
дуже уміятні [вмілі],
у нас на отручині дуже
багато є таких людей.
Ну, зараз молодих уже нема.
Але давно дуже багато виробляли:
цимбали, скрипки, все вручну!
Гуцули дуже такі запеклі.
От яка радянська влада була,
що трохи те все,
одне забороняла, одне...
Не дозволяла те продовжувати.
А люди собі декотрі
своє продовжували.
Я сам такий.
З мене багато так дивуються,
чудуються, що: «Як вам вдалося?».
Я їхав за радянської влади в Москву,
то я собі ходив в гуцульському:
постоли, штани крашéні,
сорочка тощо.
Ходив по Москві
і говорив по-українськи,
а я ні слова ні «какав»,
ні «штокав», нічого.
А жінці своїй казав,
що якби я цього дочекався,
аби радянська влада
розпалася і колгосп.
Я цього дочекався.
У Бельгію так хотіли мене,
що страшне!
Багато [куди], в Румунію...
Я не хотів нікуди їхати.
Поїхав за охотою
раз в Америку, раз у Німеччину.
У Польщу їхав кілька разів.
А багато було таких моментів,
що я відмовляв та й не хотів.
Я не дуже їхати люблю, розумієте?
Та й дні робочі,
мені зоставляти роботу...
Я дуже люблю роботу.
Одні кажуть «дудкар», а одні
кажуть «Михайло Тафійчук», а одні...
По-різному.